the tarragon experience look at even
2008 right so we have this enormous
economic collapse in 2008 housing market
sinks in these derivative mortgage
things go down and the world economy
grinds to a halt thousands of people
lose a job foreclosures all over the
place so they come in and they pump
billions of dollars into the
organizations that sunk the [ __ ] ship
in the first place yeah that's where the
money goes and I remember asking the
Treasury secretary at the time you know
this is a mortgage question right
because they the derivatives made it
like the geometric pump so if they're
bundling mortgages and eight percent of
those mortgages go underwater
it syncs the derivatives market which is
trillions of dollars as opposed to
billions of dollars so I said you know
with all that money what if you just
made those mortgages that were
underwater hope because the moment you
do that doesn't that fix your derivative
problem don't you haven't you just made
and plus then people get to keep their
houses and what he said to me was you
can't do that because of moral hazard
huh
so moral hazard is a theory that you
can't incentivize bad behavior so what
he's saying is the people that took out
mortgages on their homes that went
underwater that's their fault so you
can't bail them out because that would
be sending a hazardous message morally
about the economy so I said what's the
moral hazard then get making the people
that actually blew up the economy poll
again what's that how is that not moral
hazard and he said the plane was on fire
and we had to land why would they play
that they were the ones who lit the
plane on fire
how are you're rewarding them for that
yeah yeah it's
I've heard both sides of that argument
I've heard the argument that nope
nothing's too big to fail let it fail
and then I've heard the argument that if
it did feel fail would be so
catastrophic but I'm saying it wouldn't
have fail so it was a failure because
they oh yeah yeah they did it all to
themselves
but if you made the mortgages at the
base of that okay so let's say 10% of
the mortgages are underwater but you
know so let's say you had a $200,000
mortgage and now the house is only worth
hundred and fifty thousand dollars so
instead of given a million dollars to
AIG at the top give $50,000 to that
mortgage bring it into line with its
value suddenly that thing's not
underwater anymore
it's like putting ballast into a ship
that's sinking put the ballast then the
[ __ ] comes up rather than just saying
alright we'll buy you another [ __ ]
ship that almost seems too logical
though that's right that's kind of part
of what's the problem with all this
that's moral hazard I was just like I
don't even know what to do with that
incentivizing bad behavior doesn't count
when you're the ones who tanked the
economy and it's not it's like what
you're talking about today like if
someone tried to say that these small
businesses that are going under because
of the kovat sanctions because
everybody's been locked down rather if
if those people need to pull themselves
up by their bootstraps it's a great
example why that analogy sucks because
like there's nothing to do man you can't
work there's nothing you like what do
you want them to do there's no
opportunity it's everything shut down if
you go under at this time it's not your
fault it's one of the rare times if I'm
the government right now here's
something I could do that's like again
like it seems like a simple solution
which is like just suspend and extend
yeah so the country shut down right
what's people's oftentimes biggest worry
my rent or my mortgage yeah suspend and
extend you know what we're gonna do a
six-month suspend nobody's gonna be and
if the landlord's need to be helped out
that's what it will focus we'll make
sure that the landlord's don't go under
from having to pay too much in taxes or
having to pay too much in repairing but
attack the problem at its core which is
people's insecurities about their
unemployed they have to still pay the
rent in their mortgage or other bills
let's take a big chunk of their not
often times for people mortgage and rent
is one of the biggest nuts just [ __ ]
say like because she's clearly we have
the wherewithal on the money we're
suspending and extending everybody like
give people a chance to breathe just for
a moment and for the landlords I'm not
trying to dick them over like give them
some kind of rent a real estate tax
break or some operating expense of keep
everybody you know it's almost like like
you're a patient on a ventilator like
let's just keep everybody a [ __ ] live
yeah till we get past this moment
because they keep saying well we got a
you know we got a reopen the economy we
are the economy right there is no
corporations maybe people but these
corporations still can't catch coal but
we can so I don't understand why they
don't do something that seems simple and
addresses like a real concern grassroots
Hana on the floor again you're speaking
to logically I think it's uh it's just a
it's such a difficult time to
politically because the the ideas get
segmented into left or right right like
even the ideas of how to address kovat
how to address the economy how to
address all the everything becomes
politicized and that's that's turnover
yes it's really unfortunate because well
it's even yeah it's it's it shouldn't be
that way and I'm not sure how it started
that way and it's really unfortunate
[Applause]